what do you think is the level of
frustration from fans other influencers
when you say something like this what do
you think upset them the most
the relationship with you and the fan
you know fans when they run up to you
they feel like they've known you yeah
it's kind of like they were just kicking
it with you yes it's kind of weird when
you talk to a fan and a fan today is
very different than a fan of 20 years
ago it's a fan of 20 years ago is you
only see that Hollywood celebrity in a
movie
so it's like oh my God it's Sylvester
Stallone but the fan today is he watches
you every day on a podcast every day on
Instagram every day on Tick Tock it's
not just a fan it's my boy yeah it's my
you know so what was what was what
disappointment did you experience with
defense what do you think they're
thinking and and they really know me I
mean I I first thing I do I get up I
make a good morning Story I mean I'm
filming stories all throughout the day
every single day you know to let people
in yeah and I think uh I don't know how
really to answer this other than um I
let them all down you know um
I said that I didn't do this thing I
said that I didn't do steroids this
whole time you know and I've been doing
them and so I think that when you're
dishonest with with somebody when you
mislead somebody
um I believe that what they feel is
betrayed you know and and so what I try
to share back is
um
first thing I always want to say is I
apologize for this I did this I did this
um I own that and and I know what I did
was wrong but what I try and make sure
everybody understands is the North Star
is that 4 000 people today actually kill
themselves that 80 000 people that they
try that 85 percent of the population
has self-esteem issues 80 struggle
paycheck to paycheck and there's a
reason right like why do we live beyond
our means right why are we trying to
project our status our worth our
potential with [ __ ] that you put on your
on your wrist with what you call with
the car that you drive you know 70 of
the population is overweight half were
obese 50 on prescription medicine forty
percent have or will get cancer and
twenty percent want to have kids and
can't have kids that minor star is that
the world is hurting at record rates my
kids couldn't breathe they had to go by
ambulance to the hospital year after
year after year ancestral living was our
Salvation And I know how badly people
are hurting right so I feel that I've
been disloyal I feel like I have
betrayed I think that this is probably
the sentiment that I betrayed them and
so what I try to share back is um I just
ask for you to do two things you know
the the facts are the facts these
statistics I know how desperately people
are hurting and I believe with my heart
and soul that there's a better life it's
a simple way of living it's the
ancestral lifestyle so the the sentiment
you know that I'm getting from a lot of
people that I read is um hey Ben you let
me down I believed in you you let me
down
um I'm actually shocked at the favorable
sentiment that hey you know uh even
though you did this you were mad enough
to come forward here's how you've
changed my life and I'm like holy [ __ ]
man like I just start reading some of
these DMS and so many kids you know who
are living a better life and I'm like
well I gotta keep doing this that's a
powerful message by the way like
everything you just said about
being a better person and how much
people are struggling in depression like
if you just stuck with that message
right and just continued to work out and
didn't do steroids but still look like a
massive [ __ ] caveman animal
wouldn't the message still be as
powerful right like why do you need
steroids to to embrace that message yeah
the steroids don't for the message the
steroids are for me you know um somebody
asked me hey cut all the [ __ ] [ __ ]
give it to me in one line I don't know
if this is one line but I think what it
really boils down to is number one over
training and number two in my self-worth
and and so what's required of me to go
to bed at night to look in the mirror
and be like hey man you're okay you're
worth it you earned it you did what you
need to do right to be your best
um for me to sleep okay at night I have
to put myself in the gym twice a day to
kill myself to crush myself to destroy
myself and it's at least twice a day
this is what I publicly say you know a
lot of times I'm getting in there a
third or a fourth time you know and and
that's what is required of being right
to feel like I did it you know I don't
know if you've ever gotten something
that you didn't earn and you know you
could have earned it and if that happens
over and over and over and so
um so for me this may made a big
difference Peds made a difference for me
to allow myself to get into to maintain
two of these workouts a day and the
dangerous thing is after peties I'm like
oh [ __ ] I can get in here maybe a third
time maybe a fourth time and so for the
first time today um what I talked about
is okay well why do I need to do that
you know someone asked me actually the
other day today's the first time I ever
talked about it and uh and I've never
dealt with this before you know I don't
really I've never really believed that
trying to talk about some of my
deep-seated [ __ ] in the past I'm like
you know what I got a chip on my
shoulder good good
um so I started talking about okay so
why do I need to do that and so I think
what it really
um Harkens back to is my life from when
I was 10 to 15 years old was just a
[ __ ] hell hole I was the only one of
my kindness school I was Tiny I was just
a tiny kid I was the only white kid at
school everyone else spoke Spanish
everyone was so much bigger everyone had
body hair except for me they were a foot
taller than me that explains the beard
now you're just like [ __ ] I'm going
on I'm beating it up man thank God this
is you that's me at 15. bro you're not a
tiny kid at all you're talking but he's
well by the way that's 15 and this is
what I'm getting at and so so what I'm
getting at is
um every day I'm getting the [ __ ] kicked
out of me and I don't fight back not
once you know people are just punching
me and and many times shaking ass
whooping well many times I got knocked
out and and the bell had already rung
and I got a fight by bug bag half the
time they hit it most of the time it was
in the trash can I already [ __ ] know
my book bag's gone it's probably in the
trash can and then you got to try and
figure out what period is it what class
am I supposed to be in most of the time
you go to the wrong [ __ ] class
um and that that happened for so many
years that um I remember I would look at
the mirror and I had zero self-worth I
was I was totally embarrassed I was
humiliated of like I became this guy and
I wanted to be anything different except
for this [ __ ] guy I did not want to
be this guy
um anyway so I I went through that
probably from about you know 10 to 14 10
to 15. I started I've been working out
actually for it for a little while
um but probably around 13 14 somebody
said hey man you look pretty strong like
holy [ __ ] really you think I look strong
and so I doubled down on all that stuff
there's a whole lot more to the store I
don't know if you guys want to hear it
but
um we do I actually because I think
they're
you know I do want to hear it and I want
to go through it because I think there's
a lot of people that need to hear who
are going through it and it's a very
lonely place and you know when you hear
these stories about why did you become a
UFC fighter I got bullied growing up why
did you become a you know boxer because
I got bullied growing up why'd you go do
bodybuilding because I was sick and
tired of people pushing me around I
wanted to intimidate him through my
muscles why'd you why are you so
relentless and successful because I
couldn't stand being bullied and I
didn't see of somebody of value because
I was always compared to this kid or
that kid that's very natural to go
through that but and by the way again uh
I appreciate you being sincere and being
straight up and and you're not going to
be talking about this a year from now
two years from now five years from now
it's just you do it right now the pain
happens you move on you go to the next
thing and people are going to leave you
alone one thing about the world I've
learned my dad told me something very
interesting when
we saw Kobe delayed Kobe and we're Die
Hard Kobe guys and you know we're in La
so that's that's like our guy like
Kobe's my guy a friend a guy that I
really admired watching he's an August
23rd 78 baby I'm in October 1878 baby
when he came to La we grew up with this
guy right so when he went through some
of the stuff
and you saw him fall my dad would say
let me tell you one thing about America
here's what America is all about for
whatever reason Americans fiend seen a
man fall and be publicly humiliated he
says but you know what Americans love
more I said what they love Redemption
they love Redemption stories I just got
the chills all over my body he says they
love Redemption stories he says you may
fall one day don't worry about it they
love redemption in America it's a good
story to be thinking about that because
that is the DNA of America so with all
the craziness taking place I believe
future looks right if you believe future
looks bright get your latest Future
looks bright hat of valuetainment it
says future looks bright here future
looks bright here we got them in white
we got them in Black we got them in red
are black on black sold out these are
about to sell out if you haven't ordered
one yet we had a person in Michigan but
one then he bought three then when those
three people were in the office they had
to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody saying future looks
spread toward your future looks bright
hat click over here and to watch the
entire podcast click here take care
everybody
[Music]